COME ANDREW McCABE AND OTHERS
IN THE CROSS HAIRS, LAURA.
>> Laura: GOODY-GOODY, ED,
THINK IS MUCH GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY AND
GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE, FORMER
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR A GREAT JOB, GREAT
TO SEE YOU.
ALL RIGHT, GOVERNOR WE HEARD
FROM HILLARY CLINTON TONIGHT FOR
GOING ON AND ON AND ON AND
PREDICTING TRUMP IS GOING TO WIN
BASICALLY AND LEGITIMIZE TRUMP
REELECTION TONIGHT, BUT THE
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO HAVE THIS
PROBLEM WITH THE WORD SPYING
STILL.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING TO YOU.
THIS HAS VARIOUS CABLE NETWORKS
AROUND APRIL 10TH.
LET'S WATCH.
THIS PRIZE A A DUMB XP 12
WARRANT TO SURVEY AND SPY ON
CARTER PAGE IS IN OCTOBER 2016.
>> THE APPLICATION TO SPY ON
CARTER PAGE'S 50 PAGES LONG.
>> WHEN THEY SPIED ON TRUMP
CAMPAIGN CARTER PAGE.
THE APPLICATION TO SPY ON PAGE
WAS APPROVED BY THE PRESIDENT'S
OWN DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> Laura: CELESTE APRIL THEY
HAD NO PROBLEM WITH IT.
CALLING IT SPYING BUT HOW DARE
YOU USE THE WORD SPYING.
>> Mike: I THOUGHT HE DID A
MASTERFUL JOB TO SPELL OUT WHAT
THAT MEANT GOING BACK TO HIS
BACKGROUND.
THE BIGGER PROBLEM FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, THEY'VE GOT NOTHING.
THEY ARE LIKE PEOPLE WHO SHOW UP
AT THE BARBECUE RESTAURANT AT
CLOSING TIME AND ALL THE MEAT IS
GONE.
WHAT THEY ARE LEFT TO DO IS LICK
THE BONES, GNAW ON IT A LITTLE
BIT AND SUCK THE BARBECUE SAUCE
OUT OF THE BOTTLE.
THEY HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO DO.
AND I THINK IN A WAY, I ALMOST
FELT SORRY WATCHING THEM.
BUT THEN I DIDN'T BECAUSE SO
RUDE AND DISRESPECTFUL OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HOW HE MAINTAINED HIS COMPOSURE
AND DIDN'T CRAWL ACROSS THE
TABLE AND GO AFTER A FEW OF THEM
AS A TESTAMENT TO DIPLOMACY,
RACE AND BEING A GENTLEMAN.
>> Laura: A TRUE PROFESSIONAL,
JOE THEY ARE MAKING A BIG DEAL
ABOUT THE FACT THAT BARR SAID ON
THE HOUSE TESTIMONY TOMORROW
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
STAFF ATTORNEYS ASK THE
QUESTIONS.
FOR OUR VIEWERS OUT THERE, WHY
IS IT A PROBLEM IF STAFF
ATTORNEYS ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL?
THE STUFF YOU SEE ONLINE, PEOPLE
SAY CAN'T TAKE THE HEAT, CAN'T
TAKE QUESTIONS FROM STAFF
ATTORNEYS, BIG DEAL.
>> Joe: IT'S NOT PROTOCOL AND
NOT UNTO SENATE CONFIRM CABINET
MEMBER AND SUPPOSED BE RUSSIAN
BUT THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AND IT SEEMS ACCORDING TO
CHAIRMAN NADLER THAT NONE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS IS CAPABLE OF
ASKING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
PROPER QUESTIONS.
THAT IS A SURPRISE TO ME SINCE
MANY OF THEM ARE LAWYERS.
BUT THE ONLY TIME THAT YOU ALLOW
COUNSEL TO INTERVIEW WITNESSES
IN A HEARING IS WHEN IT'S AN
INVESTIGATIVE HEARING.
ALMOST LIKE A GRAND JURY.
YOU NEVER DO THAT FOR OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS OR BUDGET HEARINGS OR
ANYTHING.
SO, REMEMBER BILL BARR AGREED
WITH HIM AND THEN NADLER DECIDED
TO CHANGE THE RULES.
SO TYPICAL DEMOCRATIC --
DIRTY FOLD.
SURE, JUST RIDICULOUS.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR, DISGRACED
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY.
ONE OF JOE'S FAVORITE PEOPLE.
HE HAS A MAN THAT LED THE CHARGE
FOR ALL OF THESE TRUMP AGENTS.
HE IS AGAIN IN THE PROCESS OF
BLAME SHIFTING, WRITING IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OP-ED THAT
JUST CAME OUT, "MR. TRUMP, EAT
YOUR SOUL IN SMALL BITES.
MR. TRUMP MAKES EVERYONE A
COCONSPIRATOR TO HIS PREFERRED
SET OF FACTS OR DELUSIONS."
WELL, THE LACK OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY FROM THIS MAN IS
STUNNING.
>> Mike: FIRST OF ALL HIS DEAD
WRONG ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T EAT IN
SMALL BITES BUT ONE BIG CHOMP
AND OVER AND DONE WITH IT.
IT IS ONE OF THE REASONS HE'S
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE DOES KNOW
HOW TO TAKE ON AN ADVERSARY.
JIM COMEY HAS A LOT OF
EXPLAINING TO DO.
HOW HE LEAKED, HOW HE LIED --
>> Laura: YOU HEARD BARR, HE
WILL BE INVESTIGATING COMING,
RIGHT?
>> Mike: I DON'T WANT REVENGE
BUT I WANT JUSTICE.
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN OKAY LET'S
DO IT TO THEM.
I'M INTERESTED IN JUSTICE FOR
ONE REASON THE MOST POWERFUL ARM
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN GO
AFTER AND ALMOST TAKE DOWN A
SITTING PRESIDENT, WHY ON GOD'S
EARTH COULD THEY DO TO ME?
>> Laura: JAMES COMEY,
BRENNAN, CALL ME, KLAPPER.
>> Mike: AMERICA'S DIRTY COP
ATE THE SOUL OF THE FBI.
HE DESTROYED THE FBI.
IN THIS LITTLE PIECE OF PAPER,
WHICH IS THE PRIZE THAT DON'T
MAKE FISA COURT RULING FROM 2017
WHERE THE CHIEF JUDGE OUTLINES
FOUR YEARS OF LYING BY THE
OBAMA FBI AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TO THE COURT ABOUT ILLEGAL
SPYING BY THREE CONTRACTORS IS
GOING TO BE THEIR UNDOING.
AND THE COURT HAS ALREADY
INFORMED INFORMED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OF THE EXTENT OF THE
LIGHTING BY THE OBAMA FBI AND
DOJ.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
CALL ME CAN WRITE POETRY AND GO
STAND AND THE FOREST REDWOOD.
WHATEVER.
THIS GOOFY GUY, HE BETTER GET
USED TO IT BECAUSE THIS IS GOING
TO BE HIS UNDOING.
>> Laura: I DON'T WANT JOE TO
HOLD UP A PROP AND POINT AT
ME --
SCARY.
WHEN YOU HOLD UP A PROP, FORGET
IT.
BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO SPEND THE
INVESTIGATION ARE THEY NOT?
>> Mike: ABSOLUTELY.
>> Laura: THEY KNOW THEY ARE
ON THE GRIDDLE COME ON THE
GRIDDLE THESE GUYS.
>> Joe: IT IS THE KLAPPER
GRIDDLE, THEY ARE FIGHTING BACK
THE ONLY WAY THEY KNOW HOW